y en directo a vamos a hablar de
Nicaragua con nuestra corresponsal en
Costa Rica Cindy regidor porque el
gobierno de Daniel Ortega declaró como
persona no grata al embajadora de la
Unión Europea en Managua así lo reportó
la prensa local citando a Fuentes del
parlamento europeo y agregaron que se
ordenó su expulsión del país
centroamericano Cindy muy buenas noches
cuéntenos que se sabe sobre el motivo de
la expulsión
Hola Andrés como mencionas se sabe lo
que han logrado corroborar los medios
locales que han preguntado tanto el
Managua como en Bruselas qué fue lo que
ocurrió lo que se sabe es que la
embajadora recibió una comunicación
verbal por parte de un funcionario de la
cancillería nicaragüense en que le
explicaba que su expulsión o su
calificación como persona no grata era
debido a que la Unión Europea había
ejercido y respeto hacia la soberanía
nicaragüense y bueno a partir de eso
también es importante decir que un
antecedente este lunes 26 de septiembre
el delegado de la Unión Europea ante
Naciones Unidas dijo que Nicaragua
debería dejar ejercer su soberanía a los
nicaragüenses el gobierno debería dejar
a los nicaragüenses ejercer su soberanía
y que además le exhortaba a restaurar la
democracia mostró su preocupación ante
la situación de los derechos humanos y
el agravamiento de la represión en ese
país
Cindy ahora Cuál ha sido la misión de la
embajadora de la Unión Europea en
Nicaragua y como también ha sido las
relaciones entre Bruselas y el gobierno
de nicaragüense
la embajadora llegó en julio del año
pasado y en su discurso inaugural lo que
dijo Es que se dedicaría a defender los
principios de la Unión Europea entre
ellos la igualdad la libertad del Estado
de derecho el respeto por los derechos
humanos en el año que estuve en
Nicaragua se dedicó sobre todo a
apariciones en temas culturales o en
actos de cooperación y no tenía ningún
tipo de declaraciones en cuanto a lo
político quienes sí han tenido
oposiciones contundentes sobre el
gobierno actual nicaragüense ha sido los
parlamentarios de El parlamento europeo
que han votado siete resoluciones en
total desde 2018 cuando inició la crisis
en Nicaragua todas las resoluciones
votadas por una amplia mayoría son en
condena por los abusos de Derechos
Humanos cometidos por el gobierno Según
dicen estas resoluciones la más reciente
fue justamente hace una semana y en ella
los eurodiputados instaban al gobierno a
liberar de los presos políticos en
Nicaragua y se manifestaban también
preocupados por la detención de
sacerdotes y de un obispo de la Iglesia
Católica el parlamento europeo también
ha impuestos sanciones económicas a
funcionarios del gobierno nicaragüense
por corrupción y también por violaciones
de Derechos Humanos